nous altérons
le tissu de la réalité
ce qui se passe commence à se
manifester et je ne peux pas l'arrêter je
ne peux pas croire que je suis dans les saints je
dis que c'est horum et
je ne peux pas non plus saluer tout le monde je suis Tom Holland tu pourrais
me reconnaître  en tant que sympathique
Spider-Man de votre quartier, je suis ici pour
vous dire que Spidey est de retour pour une
toute nouvelle aventure dans Spider-Man, pas de chemin
à la maison, je sais que les gens le disent souvent, mais je
le pense quand je dis que vous allez voir
des choses dans ce film que vous n'avez jamais
vues auparavant, je parle de
bombes citrouilles qui
prennent d'assaut
le multivers, ce qui est d'accord, vous les avez peut-être
déjà vues, mais je vous le promets,
pas comme ça et pas ensemble.
Peter Parker se dirige enfin vers
l'université et le  la nouvelle est sortie, alors oui,
tout le monde sait qu'il est Spider-Man,
alors jetez vos théories de fans par la
fenêtre, elles ne sont probablement pas vraies ou le sont-
elles
et préparez-vous à voir l'un des
films les plus ambitieux avec lesquels nous avons jamais fait une
histoire incroyable  beaucoup de rires cardiaques,
une action de haut vol, des
effets époustouflants et des méchants fous, aucun chemin à
la maison est le point culminant de la
trilogie de retour et le début d'un
multivers de possibilités. Spiderman est
en fait Peter Parker, ma
vie entière a été foutue,
pourriez-vous faire en sorte qu'il en soit ainsi  ce mysterio n'a jamais
révélé mon identité tu es prêt à
ce qui vient de se passer
quand j'ai arrêté ce sort, nous avons commencé à
avoir des visiteurs on dirait que nous avons de la
concurrence
de tous les univers,
je promets que je réglerai ça exclusivement dans les
salles de cinéma le 17 décembre, pg-13,
où allons-nous  je ne connais pas ta
maison non je ne te tue pas je pensais que tu avais
dit que ton père m'aimait vraiment non et bien plus maintenant
bonjour Peter est-ce que je te connais nous avons commencé à
recevoir des visiteurs de tous les
univers c'est entièrement de ma faute je te le
promets  Je vais arranger ça,
nous allons nous en sortir,
nous allons en finir ensemble le
17 décembre.